and kigali respectively live to the
house of commons for the prime
minister's statement
more than 80 governments nearly half the
entire membership of the united nations
and hold bilateral talks with over 25
leaders ranging from the new presidents
of south korea and zambia to the prime
ministers of japan and jamaica
demonstrate the global reach of
britain's diplomacy and the value of our
presence at the world's top tables our
immediate priority is to join with our
allies to ensure that ukraine prevails
in her brave struggle against putin's
aggression
at the madrid summit nato exceeded all
expectations in the unity and
single-minded resolve of the alliance to
support ukraine for as long as it takes
and to explode the myth that western
democracies lack the staying power for a
prolonged crisis
all of us understand that if putin is
not stopped in ukraine he will find new
targets for his revanchist attacks and
we are not defending some abstract ideal
but the first principle of a peaceful
world which is at large and powerful
countries cannot be allowed to dismember
their neighbors
and if this was ever permitted
then no nation anywhere would be safe
therefore our goal must be for our
ukrainian friends to win
by which i mean that ukraine must have
the strength to finish this war on the
terms that president zlensky has
described
and
when putin claimed that by invading his
neighbor he would force nato away from
russia he could not have been proved
more spectacularly wrong
because the single most welcome outcome
of the madrid summit was the alliance's
agreement to admit finland and sweden
and i hope i speak for the whole house
when i say that britain
will be proud to stand alongside these
fellow democracies and reaffirm our
unshakeable pledge to come to their aid
and defend them
if ever necessary just as they would for
us
we were glad to smooth their path into
nato by giving both nations the security
assurances they needed to apply for
membership and when i met prime minister
anderson of sweden and president ninisto
of finland last wednesday i told them i
was certain that nato would be stronger
and safer for their accession
before putin's onslaught both countries
had prized their neutrality even through
all the crises of the cold war and it's
a measure of how seriously they take
today's threat that opinion in sweden
and finland has been transformed and it
speaks volumes about putin's folly that
one permanent consequences of his
consequence of his attack on ukraine
will be a doubling of the length of
nato's border with russia
if anyone
needed proof that nato is purely
defensive the fact that two
quintessentially peaceable countries
should have chosen to join demonstrates
the true nature of our alliance
and now is the time to intensify our
help for ukraine because putin's donbass
offensive is slowing down
and his overstretched army is suffering
suffering heavy casualties
and ukraine's success in forcing the
russians off snake island by sheer
weight of firepower
shows how difficult the invader will
find it
to hold the territory he has overrun
we need to equip our friends now to take
advantage of the moment when putin will
have to pause
and regroup
so nato will supply ukraine with another
billion pounds of military aid
including air defenses
drones and electronic warfare equipment
bringing our total military
humanitarian and economic support since
the 24th of february to nearly 4 billion
pounds
and to guarantee the security of our
allies
on the eastern flank
nato agreed in madrid to bolster its
high readiness forces
and we in the uk will offer even more
british forces to the alliance including
almost all of our surface fleet
we have already doubled our deployment
in estonia
and we will upgrade our national
headquarters to be led by a brigadier
and help our estonian friends to
establish their own divisional
headquarters
if you follow the trajectory trajectory
of our programmes to modernize our armed
forces mr speaker
you will draw the logical conclusion
that the uk will likely be spending 2.5
percent of gdp on defense by the end of
this decade
earlier
at the g7 summit the first full day of
talks coincided with a russian missile
destroying a ukrainian shopping center
killing at least 18 people
this barbaric attack on an obviously
civilian target strengthened the resolve
of my fellow leaders to provide ukraine
with more financial humanitarian
military and diplomatic backing for and
i quote the community again as long as
it takes
exactly the terms later echoed by nato
the g7
has pledged nearly 30 billion dollars of
financial support for ukraine this year
and we will tighten our sanctions on
russia
and the uk will join america japan
and canada to ban the import of russian
gold which previously raised more export
revenues
than anything else except
hydrocarbons
the g7 will devise more options for
ensuring that nearly 25 million tons of
grain
trapped inside ukraine by putin's
blockade reaches the countries that rely
on these supplies just as the world
economy was recovering from the pandemic
putin's war
has caused a surge in
global food and energy prices
raising the cost of living everywhere
including here at home
the g7 agreed
and i quote to take immediate action to
secure energy supply and reduce price
surges
including by exploring additional
measures such as price caps
and we will help our partners in the
developing world to meet their climate
targets and transform millions of lives
by constructing new infrastructure
according to the highest standards of
transparency and environmental
protection
through our partnership for global
infrastructure and investment an idea
launched by the uk at the carbus bay
summit last year
we will mobilize
up to 600 billion dollars
of public and private investment over
the next five years
many beneficiary nations will be members
of the commonwealth and i was very
pleased to attend the summit in kigali
of this unique association of 56 states
encompassing a third of humanity
more countries are eager to join and we
were pleased to welcome two new members
in gabon and togo
it's an amazing fact that our familiar
legal and administrative systems
combined with the english language
knock 21
off the cost of trade between
commonwealth members
and it's because the commonwealth unites
that advantage with some of the fastest
growing markets in the world
that we're using that the sovereignty
that the uk has regained to sign free
trade or economic partnership agreements
with as many commonwealth countries as
possible
so far we've done 33 including australia
and new zealand and we're aiming for
india by diwali in october
but it's true mr speaker that not every
member of the commonwealth sees putin's
aggression
as we do or exactly as we do
and it was vital to have the opportunity
to counter the myths
and to point out that food prices are
rising because putin has blockaded one
of the world's biggest
food producers
and if large countries are free to
destroy their neighbors
then no commonwealth member however
distant from ukraine would be genuinely
secure
the fact that in a week the uk was able
to deal on friendly terms with scores of
countries in three organizations shows
the extraordinary diplomatic assets our
country possesses and as we stand up for
what is right in ukraine
and advance the values and interests of
the british people i commend this
statement